bonsoir bienvenue en kiosque au menu ce
soir de votre magazine culturel la
compagnie calvero en résidence à la
merise de trappes pour la carte du temps
trois visions du moyen-orient nous avons
assisté aux dernières répétitions est
dans la chronique de nicolas gervais
aurélien bory revient sur sa série de
spectacles qu'il donne à saint quentin
en yvelines
qu'est ce que tu deviens lexus est
plombée et puissiez deux spectacles de
magie proposé ce week-end à voisins le
bretonneux avec l'association 78 tours
nous en parlerons dans quelques instants
avec nous vous invitons à nous faire
aussi que tour
elle met tout d'abord on parle théâtre
dans cette émission la compagnie calvero
était en résidence à la merise de
trappes pour les dernières répétitions
de la carte du temps trois visions du
moyen-orient une pièce autour des
conflits au moyen-orient qui sera jouée
les 12 et 14 mars prochains
sophie lieu à programmer williams elles
ont notamment rencontré le metteur en
scène roland timsit musique nous étions
des laïcs dans la famille en fait mais
surtout c'était un peu comme des juifs
des musulmans et des chrétiens pour y
dire que les fois qu'il s'en arracher un
petit pot les halles avec un petit peu
de sens mais globalement elle sent très
bien et chez tous en même temps
irak palestine israël voilà les
ingrédients de la carte du temps trois
visions du moyen-orient cette pièce
réunit des personnages démunis par un
conflit qui les dépasse
avec humour émotion et humanisme les
israéliens et palestiniens se détestent
comme il se doit enfin comme il se doit
comme ils le font malheureusement et
malgré cet antagonisme malgré cette
adversité
ils vont être obligés de ils vont être
amenés à faire quelque chose ensemble
c'est quoi ces bouffonneries ces deux
peuples qui se déchire sont très très
proches et il ya des choses que je ne
comprends mais en fait je ne comprends
pas je ne comprends pas pourquoi il ya
cette nécessité de se fracasser de se
taper de se détruire pour pouvoir vivre
côte à face voilà et ce projet l'âme
apporte des réponses
et ça c'est génial une pièce écrite par
naomi wallace une dramaturge américaine
inscrits au répertoire de la comédie
française
ce qui est très beau dans l'écriture de
naomi wallace c'est que grâce à ces
histoires qu'elle invente elle nous
permet d'imaginer nos spectateurs que ce
monde ci n'est pas le seul
en tout cas moi c'est un texte que j'ai
cherché pendant longtemps parce que je
suis en algérie et un pour moi pas ce
qui se passe au moyen-orient c'est une
deuxième blessure après un succès au
festival d'avignon en 2013 la compagnie
calvero sera sur la scène de la merise
de trappes les 12 et 14 mars pour
rencontrer aussi son public
j'aimerais qu'il se dise je les
imaginais pas comme ça les autres
l'autre que ce couac soi que je
diaboliser soi que je vis des alizés et
peut-être se dire peut-être que c'est
possible
peut-être que ce monde ci n'est pas le
seul aurélien bory est entre théâtre et
danse il propose plusieurs spectacles à
saint quentin en yvelines nicolas
gervais à la rencontrer qu'est ce que tu
deviens il ya peu au prisme plan b les
26 et 28 mars au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et flic juste
les 19 et 20 mai toujours au théâtre
aurélien bory est très présent cette
saison à saint quentin en yvelines
l'occasion de redécouvrir une oeuvre
prolixe et variés internationalement
reconnues rencontre
à
le fait d'avoir truqué trois spectacles
programmés à saint quentin c'est une
grande chance pour moi parce que
j'espère que que le public pourra voir
plusieurs de ses spectacles là c'est en
plus trois spectacles complètement
différent ça me fait plaisir parce que
je travaille beaucoup sur l'idée du
renouvellement à chaque création j'ai
envie de partir sur entre guillemets un
autre type de théâtre
plexus en fait est une création du fonds
en 2012 sur l'idée de faire un portrait
d'une personne dans cette série là les
personnes sont des femmes et sont des
danseuses et j'essaye de voir comment la
danse peut nous révéler quelque chose du
paysage intérieur d'une personne dans
mon travail des espaces bien toujours en
premier j'aborde le théâtre comme un art
de l'espace et donc j'essaye de prendre
de remplir sa des spas cela de me saisir
de l'espace de la scène est quelque part
avec ses portraits l'ajnfl inverse
je suis parti de la personne
l'idée du dispositif vient au fur et à
mesure pour kaori j'avais cinq ou six
dispositifs et finalement j'ai commencé
à travailler avec les fils j'avais
notamment fait fabriquer une marionnette
à fils à l'éffigie de kaori elle a
travaillé avec cette marionnette à fils
j'ai dit à kaori voici ton professeur de
danse faut que tu le suivent cette
marionnette là et finalement ce qui
m'intéressait c'était les fils donc j'ai
enlevé la marionnette et j'ai gardé les
fils kaori à danser a commencé à danser
avec ses filles et le mahdi aurélien
c'est comme si j'avais toujours pensé
contre son fils
quelque part plexus part du tout
intérieur presque de l'intérieur du
corps et va vers un tout extérieur
filmant dans ses portraits avec kaori
ito c'est la même chose c'est le
dialogue intérieur extérieur une grande
notion de solitude et le dialogue
intérieur extérieur qui est très très
présent plexus et qu'est ce que tu
deviens sont des pièces qui sont qui
sont beaucoup sur l'existence et avec
une présence quand même très forte de
cette fin de l'existence qu'est la mort
et puis avec kaori on s'est rencontré en
2007 et ça a été une longue période de
discussions de dialogue
le projet a beaucoup évolué j'ai besoin
de ce temps de connaître vraiment la
personne que la personne devienne comme
une soeur c'est une artiste qui a
beaucoup de facettes il son histoire le
fait qu'elle soit partie du japon à 18
ans pour pratiquer la danse aussi aux
états unis puis en europe
le fait qu'aujourd'hui elle est lé plus
française que japonaise
même si tout ça ça transpire ça
transparaît pas j'ai pas envie de
raconter cette histoire dans les
portraits je m'appuie sur ces éléments
biographiques s'en est ensuite ça
devient un peu plus abstrait on va dire
mon spectacle mais je touche en partant
d'une personne à des questions
universelles ce qui m'intéressait dans
le dispositif pour qu'est ce que tu
deviens ou pour plexus c'est de mettre
un obstacle à la danse un espace
impossible à danser et de voir dans
cette confrontation là dans cet obstacle
las de voir qu'est-ce qui résiste à cet
obstacle
qu'est ce qui finalement va sublimer
l'obstacle
qu'est ce qui va rester dès lors qu'on
empêche quelqu'un de danser
oh
on retrouve complètement cette idée du
dispositif comme centre
comme point de départ du travail dans
plan b la dent plombé c'était un
présupposé c'était le plan d'abord
inclinée verticales horizontales et
c'est aussi un espace entre guillemets
impossible ou du moins un espace pas
impossible mais un espace qui modifie le
rapport à la gravité
le mouvement du décor définit une
certaine dramaturgie ou le monde
n'arrête pas de bouger et les les hommes
les êtres humains s'adapte à cet espace
qui n'arrête pas un spectacle qui a été
créée il ya plus de dix ans qui a fait
plusieurs fois le tour du monde que les
voulu maintenir au répertoire donc j'ai
repris en 2012 avec une nouvelle équipe
ça a été un travail je dirais
emblématique de la compagnie marqué par
la collaboration que j'ai eu avec phil
saltanov qui est un metteur en scène
américain qui m'a beaucoup marqué qui
m'a beaucoup appris en 2012 on a repris
avec quatre nouveaux interprètes et
c'est un plaisir un bonheur de rejouer
ce spectacle de continuer à le tourner
ce costume l'un qui est un peu le
costume qui représente le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est un code c'est un
habit que vous ne choisissez pas la
deuxième raison qui est liée à la
première c'est que du coup il ya l'idée
de d'hommes ordinaires qui ne se
distingue pas par part à leur façon de
s'habiller ya cette idée de se conformer
évidemment tout ça ne va pas avec ce
qu'on fait dans le spectacle ils ont
aussi envie d'être complètement dans ce
monde là mais le monde bouge se
transforme en permanence ils n'ont
d'autre choix que de s'adapter et se
prendre un peu les les pieds dans le
tapis
et voilà maintenant il fait nuit
magie du cinéma le temps ne passe pas
pareil pour nous bref après les
pirouettes de relier un bruit voici
catherine en celte au plateau en plateau
allez on continue à parler dans ce
monsieur et madame rêve le dernier
spectacle mis en scène par marie claude
pietragalla proposé ce samedi soir à la
ferme du manet de montigny le bretonneux
un spectacle autour de l'irréalité et
virtuels tarif à partir de 29 euros je
vous propose un extrait
et je vous propose maintenant des dates
de concerts à retenir direction d'abord
le prisme à elancourt pour un concert de
duke l'analyste david krakauer et le
coiffeur à barinas samedi 14 mars à 21h
tarifs à partir de 16 euros le new
yorkais s'est emparé du klezmer c'est la
rencontre entre la musique juive
d'europe de l'est de jazz de la new
orleans revisité par new york pour
donner une vision plus électrique est
plus festive en voici un extrait
toujours en musique la deuxième édition
du tremplin rock the chase ce samedi
soir la salle gauguin de montigny le
bretonneux tarifs à partir de 3 euros 30
un jury de près de présélection composé
d'étudiants de professionnels du secteur
et d'élus locaux a sélectionné les cinq
groupes entre pop rock et reggae venez
donc nombreux pour les soutenir et voter
car celui qui sera élu fera la première
partie d'un groupe professionnel
programmées durant la saison 2015 2016 à
montigny le bretonneux
autre ambiance musicale cette fois en
l'église saint germain de paris sia
magny les hameaux
ce dimanche après-midi avec l'ensemble
vocal l'offrande lyrique l'association
plaire de org organise un concert de
musique baroque européenne tarifs de 5 à
12 euros
et puis on terminait à cet agenda
musique bien fournie avec le festival
ap harpe en scène qui rassemble 60
harpiste les 13 et 14 mars à la grange
de la tramblais de bois d'arcy
l'occasion de découvrir des instruments
très différents les uns des autres
de la harpe baroque à triple rond de
cordes à la harpe électrique ou
celtiques tous les concerts sont en
entrée libre
on poursuit il ce magazine avec la magie
la magie revient à voisins le bretonneux
l'association 78 tours présente son
nouveau spectacle sapristi ce samedi à
la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux et pour en parler
j'ai deux magiciens sont très bien
encadrés ce soir samedi
bonsoir vous êtes un magicien présidente
de l'association et claude saloni
bonsoir vous êtes également magicien et
adhérents de l'association ya deux
parties dans ce spectacle il ya une
première partie à 15 heures pour les
enfants et qu'une partie pour une
famille à 20 heures claude saloni la
partie enfants spéciale on s'est dit que
c'était très spécial parce que les
enfants il nous parle de ne rien parce
qu' ils sont francs ils disent ce qu'ils
voyaient et c'est donc quand les jeunes
les adultes sont plus polis ils vont
voir quelque chose ils vont rien dire
alors que l'enfant il va crier tout de
suite ouais j'ai vu le film j'ai vu
c'est à dire que du coup pour le
spectacle on sait on s'adapte alors on
fait des choses vraiment visuel pour les
enfants des choses plus magie comique
magie de colombes
enfin de tout ce qui intéresse les
animaux enfin et c est ça intéresse bien
les enfants et on a aussi du close up
dans la salle c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir des magiciens du club qui vont
pendant la tente pendant les les pauses
et c'est qu'ils vont faire de la magie
devant soi ce qui est vous nous voyez
très peu habituellement quoi donc celle
avantage d'avoir un club de magie c'est
que on propose des choses que vous ne
trouvez pas dans les salles de spectacle
et ça veut dire qu'est ce que vous
faites aussi participer les enfants s
qui monte sur scène je vais bien sûr
bien sûr il sera si friands sont très
friands laurent général ils sont tous
assis devant ils iront mais des tapis
devant et puis ils viennent s'asseoir
devant donc ils sont vraiment aux
premières loges et puis ce grand l'effet
faire participer cette année donc à une
première partie à 15 heures pour les
enfants ce samedi une deuxième partie
pour les enfants puis pour les grands
aussi pour toute la famille voilà donc
plainte à 20h30 c'est un spectacle plus
familial maintenance et ce pour les
adultes comme pour les enfants
mais effectivement c'est plus orienté
pour les plus grands on va dire c'est
pas que l'après midi c'est vraiment
réservé aux enfants c'est que des
numéros pour enfants on retrouvera
certains numéros de l'après midi on les
retrouvera le soir mais c'est pas
exactement le même poids là mais c'est
vraiment familial faut pas hésiter à
venir avec des enfants de 6 7 ans le
soir il ya deux arrivants comme motif de
ce spectacle vous proposer le soir vient
vous dire que cette année cette année on
a pas mal de nouveaux membres dans dans
l'association donc on a aussi des
nouvelles
des nouvelles choses et nouveau numéro
il ya des très bons numéros de
manipulateurs des tours à thème je pense
à bruno là qui nous fait un super numéro
avec des décès des manipulations de
céder avec tout un thème très
intéressant il ya des grandes illusions
aussi donc des trucks avec des boîtes on
découpe des gens en morceaux c'est pas
toujours évident parce que cinq la salle
de la tour n'est pas très grande
donc c'est assez intime comme spectacle
mais il y aura quand même des grandes
illusions des choses avec des animaux
donc voilà pas mal de choses dans la
magie skd forcément des tours qui plaît
oui en ce moment c'est le mentalisme a
laissé ça vous en faites vous je vous en
fais d'accord de la transmission vous
connaissez ces cartes c'est des cartes
je peux démontrer qu'ils ont des formes
assez simple et ils ont été développés
pour faire des tests de transmission de
pensée
d'accord on les années 80 on peut donc
on va essayer donc je veux je vais
choisir alors vous essayez de deviner ce
que j'ai choisi
donc allez-y en placer une
la place d'abord pourquoi que je vais en
france parce que mettez là comme ça
parce que il faut alors essayé on va
finir deuxième
c'est une troisième est comme ça ouais
heures j'ai ici ça hop
est ce que vous êtes bien synchro avec
moi barça si on est bien sacro en deux à
voir la brume déjà ah oui c'est déjà pas
mal
on a la même et puis alors alors est ce
qu ont été vos cartes on va les
retourner un donc la première du dessus
non de chick
voilà un c'est bien la deuxième aulas je
sais bien
la troisième c'est bien et la quatrième
c'est bien c'est un cas très bien vu ou
pas ont peut-être pas bien vu mais en
tout cas c'est clair tout et synchro a
ouai c'est moi il n'y a pas de souci
tous les cinq ont donc ça ça marche très
bien
voilà genre de tour qui fonctionne voilà
ça c'est du mentalisme c'est vraiment
plus pour adultes 10 e rang donc c'est
pas moi qui ai du mentalisme mieux parce
qu'en fait c'est quelque chose dans la
main c'est pour ça qu'il est beau parce
qu'en fait il est affamé
parce qu'en fait vous avez oublié de
l'art de lui donner à manger voilà ils
mangent et dorment ils vont poser une
question bah oui donc alors sur la
torture des animaux non non sur le club
de 10,78 toi le club existe la solution
existe depuis combien de temps vous avez
dit vous aviez nous gagnons en nombre
d'adhérents alors vous êtes aujourd'hui
combien alors l'association existe
depuis 2004
moi je suis le président depuis 2008 et
nous sommes 35 35 membres à ce jour ce
qui est ce qui est pas mal puisque
vraiment chaque année on augmente nous
nos effectifs donc plein de nouveaux
talents et on a des gamins aussi on a
vraiment des douze ans et puis je sais
plus combien la fille à cristaux elle
doit avoir lu et 9 ans 8-9 en asie siens
on est d'ailleurs vraiment on prend même
des magiciens des enfants le problème
c'est le soir on sait que c'est une
réunion signé sa marque encore à quel
moment vous réunissez ou alors tout
c'est tous les jeudis soir entre 20h30
et 23h donc c'est pour avant tout des
passionnés de magie ce n'est pas une
école de magie on donne pas de cours de
magie
c'est une réunion de passionnés magie on
échange entre nous on prépare les
spectacles on a notamment notre festival
de magic est prévue fin mai donc 29 30
et 31 mai donc trois jours de folie
vous avez un enfant qui vient forcément
vous leur donnez bien monstre mais quand
même bien on s'est régalé magicienne pas
trop en dévoiler leur ces normes et
souvent cédé des enfants qui ont envie
de voeux et donc ils ont déjà des choses
ils ont déjà appris quelque chose ils
ont acheté une boîte de machines on leur
a offert à noël une boîte de magie et
c'est d'ailleurs tout le monde peut
devenir magicien où il faut quand même
avoir acquis
talent à la fois 2 à 1 pour seulement un
petit talent quelque chose quoi en pull
à sion en fait je me pose est vraiment
la question si vous peut-être peut-être
que vous pouvez être magicienne je ne
sais pas un jour sans un potentiel
je comprenais pas ce qui va m'arriver
parce que catherine pour savoir si on
est préparé à faire de la magie
donnez moi votre main oui ah ouais non
mais les temps du premier tour et bougez
pas bougé pas bon ne vous inquiétez pas
j'étais médecin ostéopathe un certain
temps mais en fait c'était pour savoir
si si je peux tenter une prédiction
ouais mais j'ai des soucis avec les
ports alors j'ai ici une prédiction qui
est la moins saine et encore on n'a rien
préparé
oui c'est vraiment je dis on n'a rien
prévu les spectateurs n'a vraiment rien
de pareil donc ça peut rater je sais pas
trop on va voir ça catherine je vais
demander tout simplement de penser une
carte ou éditoriaux surtout une carte de
jeu une carte de jouer tout à fait
d'accord car de carthage se repaître 6 à
8 3 me voulait et une couleur taclant
simplement c'est bon c'est déjà
ouais alors en fait le but du jeu c'est
de la transmission de pensée donc vous
allez me l'envoyer mentalement allez-y
c'est bon c'est vrai je pense que la
prédiction est bonne et la prédiction et
dans cette boîte non si la caméra peut
vraiment rester sur catherine on va
faire la révélation et c'est sûr moins
bon et là ça c'est en direct alors si si
ça fonctionne pas mais bon c'est pas
grave on croit pas il vous davis et ils
vont regarder la carte compris voilà
très magiciens sont aussi des blagues
vous avez tort ce type
voilà des plaques c'est vraiment voilà
donc la magie c'est avant tout de
l'humour pour les grands pour les petits
il ya vraiment des choses voilà quand
même sérieusement il ya quand même un
cocktail était quand elle m'a j comme
pour faire réagir le coup
oui c'est comme un débat c'est un peu
comme
un quelqu'un au théâtre c'est plutôt en
faut apprendre à présenter par les
phares etc
donc c'est une école aussi un peu de
d'ailleurs pour les enfants timides
c'est très bien parce que justement ils
apprennent à s'exprimer ils apprennent à
se dépasser et c'est donc effectivement
c'est mais il faut pouvoir parler aux
gens il faut pouvoir se mettre en avant
quoi mais les tours par eux mêmes ça
dépend à près de votre le genre que vous
avez si vous êtes magiciens comique si
vous êtes mentalist voilà il ya plein de
styles chacun peut trouver son style
gangsta qui frise encore nous faire un
truc vous avez lé 30 secondes avant de
conclure non c'est trop tard donc se
jouer dans une autre la wii une petite
erreur promise à la colombe à collomb
qui s'envole
si la colombie voilà qui s'envole sur le
plateau d'abord brillé sur les
projecteurs ici c'est clair c'est clair
remerciant tout cas vous donne est
revenu en plateau merci à tous vos mots
animaux et compagnons qui sont venus à
celle d'antan on l'attend peut-être pas
mais elle est en train de recoller merci
à vous d'être en pleine forme voilà
samedi prend la balle au champ d'honneur
c'est à 15h et à 20h30 salle en pleine
forme avec ses copines samedi 15 heures
salle de la tour ou samedi 20h30 et où
et samedi 29 cents à 105 euros l'après
midi comment ils allaient ils ne font
bien merci de 40 euros le soir pour les
enfers et 12 euros
ce n'est pas toi c'est encore quelques
instants avec moi allez on finit cette
émission avec évidemment la chronique
cinéphiles ce soir exceptionnellement la
chronique cinéphiles vous ne retrouverez
pas les avis de spectateurs mais place
tout de suite au coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du septième art ce soir
lui peau quand on dessine et 7 des
encours
alors deux coups de coeur cette semaine
aussi 17
le premier c'est une comédie policière
espionnage d' aventure qui s'appelle
kingspan avec l'acteur oscarisé colin
firth qui nous donne là une
interprétation tout à fait sublime en
agent secret on va dire rater qu'on
vient chercher malgré lui et qui va
résoudre malgré lui encore une fois tout
un tas d'affaires
alors c'est un film qui représente un
genre assez peu enfin je trouve
représentés dans les salles de cinéma
c'est le film politiquement incorrect
originale qui part un peu dans tous les
sens mais qui est très bien fait l'on
sait vraiment à découvrir ces savoureux
c'est à ces manières
que l'on juge un homme vous savez ce que
ça veut dire
alors je vais éclairer votre lanterne on
va traîner là toute la journée
où est ce qu'on va se battre
franchement un havrais j'avais besoin de
décompresser et puis le deuxième coup de
coeur c'est une opération qu'on monte
régulièrement avec le service culture de
la ville d'elancourt qui s'appelle
cinéart et donc on aura donc une séance
dimanche à 18h du chef-d'oeuvre du film
on va dire maintenant de patrimoine
d'antonioni qui s'appelle blow up voilà
est ce film sera suivie d'une conférence
de gabriel du verrou qui parlera à la
fois du travail de cinéaste d'antonioni
mais aussi du travail des photographes
en particulier voilà et ça c'est
dimanche à 18 heures
cette émission est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi rendez vous la
semaine prochaine bonne forêt